okay so in Chains to Man episode 5 we
were introduced to the concept of the
gun devil and today we're about to solve
one of the biggest mysteries surrounding
it during this video I'll be piecing
together Clues from the manga to show
you how patrice's arrival in Japan and
the gun Devil's disappearance are both
directly connected on top of that I'll
also take you through the origin of why
makama began working for the Japanese
government in the first place and as
long as you stick around to the end then
I can guarantee you'll see how all the
evidence fits together before we get
into it though for the first half of
this video I wanted to explain some
details about the gun Devil's backstory
that the anime left out which will help
us to fully understand the theory in the
second half
all right so as the name suggests the
gun devil is the physical manifestation
of Humanity's fear of guns and its
origin goes back to the year 1984.
during that year civilians around the
world were buying tons of firearms as a
way of protecting themselves against
Devils but this Behavior had a knock-on
effect on society as macama said more
people having guns led to an increase in
gum-related crime and an increase in
civil unrest in some parts of the world
with all of that craziness going on it
meant that the media was consistently
talking about gun violence creating a
chain reaction where people then started
to become more fearful towards Firearms
themselves given that the strength of
any devil depends on how many people are
afraid of it the gun Devil's power was
quietly growing throughout the early
1980s until eventually it showed up in
1984. on the 18th of November of that
year following a gun-related terrorist
attack in America the gun devil went on
a rampage across the entire planet
killing 1.2 million people although
episode 5 didn't show its physical
appearance in the manga it has a giant
handgun sticking straight through its
skull and inside its rib cage major
hundreds if not thousands of screaming
heads when we take a closer look you can
see that each face does have their own
individual features for instance some
have mustaches and stubble whereas
others are clean shaven and it got me
thinking that these are probably actual
people my initial thought is that these
are just innocent humans who were
offered to the gun Devil by the American
government which is a conspiracy that
I'll be discussing in more detail when
we get to the theory part of the video
alternatively maybe the gun devil just
has the ability to harvest The Souls of
certain men that it kills but the ones
here being selected perhaps based on
their age or whether or not they have a
shiny bald head as ridiculous as that
sounds something like that wouldn't be
that surprising because the gun devil
does have some weirdly specific powers
for example Drew one of his massacres it
had the ability to Target and kill every
living thing except people who were born
in the months of April July and October
another example is how he was able to
kill adult men within a certain radius
whereas adult women inside that radius
still had a chance of survival when you
have powers as specific as that based on
things like gender and the Month people
were born I feel like stealing Souls
based on certain criteria like age and
other things you know it's not that
crazy of an idea anyway like I was
saying in 1984 the gun devil went on a
rampage and wiped out over half a
million Americans in just under two
minutes its insane level of speed meant
that it could do this and then travel to
other nations within a few seconds in
fact it was so fast that pieces of his
flesh tore off as it was speeding
through the air thanks to machama's
words in the manga we know that the gun
then went on to murder 8 000 people in
Canada 6 000 people in Mexico 58 000
people in Japan and nearly 30 000 in
India later on over 155 000 were killed
in the Soviet Union as well but because
the country was so massive it took the
gun devil nearly four whole minutes to
finish the job out of all the nations
that got attacked this was by far the
longest time the gun spent in any one
place where the shortest time being the
0.4 seconds it spent in Hawaii the fact
Hawaii is noted down as its own
individual country heavily implies that
it never became part of the US in this
timeline which I thought was a nice
detail that sadly wasn't mentioned in
the anime another small detail that was
harder to work out is the order in which
each of these countries got hit by the
gun devil because the manga only gives
us two Clues the most significant clue
comes in chapter 73 when it's insinuated
that the Soviet Union was the final
place to get blitzed and the other clue
comes in Chapter 13 when we find out
that Japan got hit at exactly 10 am no
other country was given a precise time
of day like this so I guess we can
assume that Japan might have been the
first one but regardless the attack only
lasted for 26 seconds during those brief
moments entire cities were flattened and
countless homes were destroyed including
the home of the hayakawa family when the
gun devil arrived in Japan Aki and his
brother were having a snowball fight
outside but as tires hands got called
Aki innocently sent him to get gloves it
was at that exact moment that their
house and Aki's entire family were torn
to shreds in front of his eyes and while
it's obviously not his fault you have to
imagine that he feels some kind of guilt
or regret about the exact way things
happened that guilt and regret likely
contributes to his demeanor and you know
his desire to get revenge against the
gun and the only way he can do that is
by finding the pieces of Flesh these
tiny bullets are super important to
locating the gun Devil's main body which
in the anime is currently in an unknown
location and hasn't been seen since the
day of the attack now with that
explained it's time to move on to how
the gun Devil's appearance was directly
tied to chainsaw man and makima herself
in order to do this we need to discuss
info that won't be revealed in the anime
for a long time so if you're an anime
only Watcher and don't want to know
anything then this is the time to pause
the video hit that sub button and come
back when you're ready to hear a few
spoilers for everyone else it's time to
break down what really happened in the
1980s and the place we need to begin is
chapter 73. in that chapter makama
revealed some mind-blowing Intel to
denji in the gang which is that the gun
devil was actually captured by humans on
the same day it first appeared minutes
after entering the Soviet Union the
Soviet Army found its own unconscious
body lying on the ground because it had
already been defeated by an unknown
person the person who took it down was
never specified however if we piece all
the clues together so far including the
fact that pachita had two bullet wounds
during this flashback then the timeline
starts to become clear what I think
happened is that on November the 18th
pachita was in hell when he was
confronted by the control devil War
devil gun devil and a few other Devils
that show up later in the series the
evidence for this is that in chapter 87
makima stated that at some point in the
past pachita had an epic battle against
the Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse and
the weapons Devils which obviously would
have included the gun during this epic
fight in hell we know that chainsaw man
took a bite out of the war devil
significantly reducing her strength and
he also ate a few of the weapons Devils
which erased some of their names from
existence following that he and the gun
devil must have severely wounded each
other which is when the fight began to
go in a completely different Direction
with Batista being too injured to
continue he decided to escape through
one of the doors in Hell explaining why
why makima said that he vanished during
the height of the battle by the way the
Maga made it clear that many of these
doors are connected to locations on
Earth proven in chapter 84 when he uses
one of them to travel to Tokyo back in
1984 though a ninja pachita went through
a door that took him to another part of
Japan where he meets denji for the first
time suffering from serious gunshot
wounds from the gun devil his body then
morphed into a tiny orange dog which is
something machama describes his
near-death form as you saw in the anime
denji then offered human blood to help
pachita to regenerate himself and the
two of them form a binding contract
where they agree to help each other
going forward at the exact same time Dan
and Hell after chainsaw man vanish it
was confirmed that the other Devils did
try to find him my assumption is that
they each must have split up and gone
through different doors with the bomb
devil arriving in the Soviet Union the
arrow devil arriving in China the
control devil arriving in Tokyo for the
first time and the gun devil arriving
somewhere in Japan at 10 am the wounded
gun devil then blitzed through the
country looking for pachita and within a
few minutes he goes through America
Canada India and all the other nations
we mentioned earlier before finally
collapsing in the Soviet Union from his
injuries this is why the mystery person
who defeated the gun devil was nowhere
to be seen because petite had already
done the damage back when they were in
hell anyhow after the gun fell
unconscious the Soviets took what was
left of its body for themselves while
over in Japan makama began her long
search to find chainsaw man in order to
do this properly she needed certain
resources which is why she made a
contract with the Japanese prime
minister in exchange for offering her
services to the public safety double
Hunters the Prime Minister gave her a
deal in which any attacks made on her
would be transferred to random Japanese
civilians this essentially made her
invincible and thanks to the resources
in public safety she was able to track
down all of Chainsaw man's allies over
the years for example she Tracked Down
the angel devil to a remote Village and
sometime after that she captured beam
power princy and several other allies
who used to be followers of Chainsaw man
however despite all her searching she
was never able to find himself and
that's because he remained in his
near-death form making himself
unrecognizable it was only when she met
denji in 1997 that makima finally found
what she was looking for and she then
slowly began planting seeds that would
enable her to take control of Chainsaw
man for herself for the purpose of this
video it's not really necessary for me
to spoil how she tries to do this but
just know that taking control of pachita
was likely her goal all the way back
when she first confronted him in hell
switching over to the Soviet Union as we
established they were the ones who found
what was left of the gun Devil's main
body this means that in the 1980s the
Soviets would have possessed 63 percent
of the gun devil while the remaining 37
percent were scattered around the world
as Tiny bullets most of those bullets
were then consumed by lower ranking
Devils to make themselves more powerful
but what's really interesting here is
how America reacted to all of this
somehow between 1984 and 1997 the Soviet
share of Uganda was body decreased down
to just 28 percent while the US somehow
gained 20 percent of the body for
herself and a few other countries also
got some smaller percentages now for all
we know some of those countries could
have paid large amounts of money for it
but when it comes to America there's a
scene in episode 2 that makes me think
they might have just straight up stolen
it in this scene Maximus higher-ups talk
about how the American matter has made
the Soviet warhawks angry and the
definition of a Warhawk is someone who
favors war or the escalation of conflict
naturally those types of people would
would be triggered if a devil belonging
to the Soviets was taken by U.S
intelligence and I actually think this
is all meant to parallel the beginning
of the Cold War in our own reality when
the Americans developed nuclear weapons
first Soviet intelligence then used
spies to steal military secrets from the
U.S this helped the Soviets to develop
their own nuke and level the playing
field between the two countries and I
think a similar thing is happening here
as makama once said nuclear weapons
don't exist anymore in this timeline and
so the ganderbil is the closest thing
that these countries have to its
destructive power back when the Soviets
found its body in the 80s they became
the only country to have this insane
potential and so it shouldn't be
surprising that other countries would
want to get in on that the way I see it
it's possible the Soviets might have
been willing to sell 11 of the body to
China but there's absolutely no chance
they would have sold a whole 20 to
America giving away that much of the gun
devil to the US is something the Soviet
warhawks would have never allowed to
happen which is why I'm pretty sure the
American matter relates to the US taking
it through to espionage this brings me
to the conspiracy that I briefly
referenced earlier in the video which is
that the American government has
sacrificed some of its own people to the
gun in chapter 75 we saw firsthand that
countries are using Devils for military
purposes when the president made a
contract with the gun devil to kill
makima he made this deal by offering the
gun one year from the lifespan of All
American citizens and when we consider
that many of those people already had
less than one year to live the president
effectively handed over their souls
that's why I thank many of these people
here are American citizens who've had
their lives cut short and also
potentially other victims who were
sacrificed during any previous contracts
that were made between the gun devil and
the Soviet Union anyhow before we wrap
this video up there is one tiny detail
about this theory that I know some of
you are probably thinking about and that
is the issue of denji's age if we assume
that my theory is correct and that denji
met pachita in 1984 then that would mean
he's around three or four years old in
this flashback personally when I first
saw this flashback in the anime I
thought he looked around 10 years old
but for the theory to work that can't be
the case because if denji was 10 in 1984
then that would make him 23 in the
present day clearly he's not that old
although because of his crappy
upbringing no one is certain what his
exact age is according to denji he
thinks he's probably around 16 but given
that he wasn't sure about this it's
possible he could be 17 18 or even 19.
the fact is no one knows for certain not
even denji himself if he was to be 19
then that would make him around five or
six years old during this first
encounter which looks more realistic to
be honest like that could work but yeah
let me know your thoughts in the
comments down below do you think the
ages line up
anyway people if you enjoyed this video
then be sure to drop a comment below
letting me know what you think And
subscribe to the channel if you want to
see more theories like this until the
next one peace out